remember that scene from degrassi well
apparently actress cassie steele took
that blue bedazzled thong
out of storage to do tick-tock's busset
challenge
and her former co-star drake is totally
here for it
i like challenges here's what went down
cassie who played manny santos on the
hit canadian show from 2001 to 2010
recently recreated her character's
memorable look
dropping it low for the viral dance
trend
cassie captioned the clip quote for
everyone who enjoys a good throwback
outfit
it's perfect what do you think i mean
she nailed the challenge and the look
and drake who played jimmy brooks on the
teen drama
who used to go by his first and last
name aubry graham
thought she crushed it too and slid into
the comments with praise
quote fit is museum worthy to be honest
santos
yeah that fit will turn heads for sure
[Music]
but this isn't the first time the rapper
has given us those throwback to grassy
vibes
that's the only kind of [ __ ] that gets
you some respect
got a lot of blood and it's cold
they keep trying to get me for my soul
back in 2018
drake gave us major nostalgia when he
cast some of his former co-stars for his
i'm upset music video yeah that that was
cassie with a money gun
and she wasn't the only degrassi alum to
make a cameo
shane kipple nina dobrev jake epstein
stacy farber and aj saudin all popped up
too
half a million on my head i can't accept
yeah
and during the final credits drake made
sure to pay tribute to his co-stars with
side-by-side shots of each actor's
appearance in the show
next to their appearance in the music
video because i like to think drake is
like
us and dude loves a proper throwback
i'm upset
i don't know about you but all this
degrassi talk has me missing the days of
a young drake
rapping in the school gym the
[Music]
uh